في الثاني من كل عام يحتفل العالم باليوم
العالمي للتوحد الذي اصبح يوما سنويا يهدف
لزياده الوعي في هذا المرض وطريقه التعامل
مع مصابيح ويصاب بالتوحد واحد الى اثنين
من كل شخص حول العالم ويزيد في معدل
الاصابه لدى ذكور خمسه اضعاف عن الاناث
يعد هذا اليوم بابا لتسليط الضوء على
المصابين وما يواجهونه من تحديات اجتماعيه
وقدرتهم على التخلص منها ومميزاتها التي
تعد طريقا للتعامله مع الاخرين ورغم
حساسيه المرض الا ان الاف المصابين
استطاعوا التغلب عليه واصبحوا اشخاصا
فاعلين في مجتمعاتهم بمشاريع وانشطه
مختلفه ليصل بعضهم لمصافي مبدعي ونجوم
العالم
[موسيقى]
العديد من نجوم العالم
وعلمائه واثريائه مصابون بالتوحد لكنهم
تغلبوا عليه وصنعوا تاريخهم المميز النجم
الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي بطل العالم مع
المنتخب الارجنتيني في كاس العالم 2022
وصاحب لقب افضل لاعب في العالم لسبع مرات
رجل الاعمال واغنى رجل في العالم ايلون
ماسك والرئيس التنفيذي لتويتر وهو ايضا
صاحب اشهر شركه سيارات كهربائيه في العالم
تسلا مصاب بالتوحد رائد صناعه الكمبيوتر
ومؤسس شركه مايكروسوفت احدى اهم شركات
التكنولوجيا العالميه هو ايضا مصاب
بالتوحد كذلك العالم تشارلز احد اهم
العلماء في العالم وصاحب مقياس ريختر الذي
تقاس به شده الزلازل كذلك توماس اديسون
العالم الامريكي الذي اضاء العالم بصناعته
للمصباح الكهربائي فضلا عن اكثر من الف
اختراع اخر وايضا
البرت اينشتاين عالم الفيزياء الاشهر
وصاحب نظريه النسبيه النظريه الاهم في
دراسه الفيزياء الحديثه كان ايضا مصاب
بالتوحد